if you haven't seen a ventures infinity
war yet click away from this screen fast
because spoilers are coming still here
if infinity war proved nothing else
it's that directors Joe and Anthony
Russo aren't afraid to orchestrate some
devastating consequences for our
favorite superheroes
even before Thanos is heartbreaking
purged several major mainstays of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe met their
makers including Heimdall Loki Gamora
and vision it may seem inevitable that
the good guys will ultimately win in
Avengers 4 and maybe even revive many of
those lost an infinity war but it's also
just as likely that even more heroes
will fall to the mad Titan before it's
all said and done we can't definitively
predict who will or won't make it out
alive next time of course but thanks to
contract commitments of the cast the
characters comic origins and other
details we do have some educated guesses
about which characters might find
themselves on the chopping block in
Avengers 4 the First Avenger one of the
most memorable moments of the comic
Infinity Gauntlet which inspired much of
the infinity war happens when Captain
America marches on Thanos in spite of
being one of the less powerful heroes
facing him cap doesn't betray an ounce
of fear in part his attack is a ploy
caps distracting Panos
so that Silver Surfer can try to snatch
the Infinity Gauntlet away from her but
even after that effort fails cap doesn't
back down giving Bannos a crack across
the jaw before falling to the mat Titans
might we already saw something of a
tribute to this moment at the end of
infinity war but there's no way we've
seen the last of caps hopeless heroics
after all adventure sport marks the end
of Chris Evans contract with the studio
and the actor has indicated he's ready
to give up the role I don't know what's
next but but yeah by 2019 that's that's
that's it if this does end up being his
last MCU movie the film makers aren't
likely to give Captain America a quiet
retirement ceremony he already decided
he'd rather be a hero than settle down
an Avengers age of Ultron so having him
sit this one out while others take the
brunt of Thanos as punishment just isn't
his style if Captain America isn't going
to be an Avenger anymore a heroic
downfall seems like the only way to end
it the lost daughter
nebula is one of the most tragically
flawed characters of the MCU she was a
villain in the first guardians of the
galaxy film and a reluctant hero in the
second the cruelty she experiences at
the hands of her father Thanos has left
her blinded by her thirst for vengeance
against him
thanks to her unbridled bloodlust she
tends to make a lot of bad decisions her
refusal to stay with her sister in the
guardians at the end of volume 2 for
example
ultimately led to her capture by Thanos
and the torture session that inspired
Gamora to give up the goods on the soul
stones whereabouts in infinity war
without her sister around
anchor her she's bound to make even more
mistakes and this time it may cost her
her life even if her characters arc
follows the comics and sees her seize
control of the gauntlet
that's not exactly good news for nebula
either expect her to finally fall at the
hands of her adopted father the
challenger to the throne comics fans may
have been a bit surprised by the courage
and nobility displayed by mbaku in black
panther and infinity war he's primarily
known as the villain man ape in the
comics so mbaku sunscreen challenge to
two challahs throne was to be expected
his last-minute supported the king
however was a much less obvious route
one wall white and I will feed you to my
children
I'm keeping 100 Tyrion's but the mbaku
of both the page and the screen cares
for his people the Jabari before all
else with touch Allah being one of the
victims of Thanos his purge in Baku
finds himself in an unusual position
what Conda is defeated so he could use
to chalice absence as a chance to seize
the throne even though his days would
probably be numbered either T'Challa
would take him out upon his inevitable
return or Okoye or Shuri would do the
job for him baku could also join the
other heroes and even then his number
would likely come up anyway the chances
of a mbaku solo film franchise are
pretty thin the named cast of Black
Panther involved in infinity war is due
to lose some of its numbers the last
guardian of all the survivors of
infinity war Rocket Raccoon will likely
enter Avengers 4 as the most distraught
not only did he witness groots
tear-jerking final moments but if and
when the survivors from Titan get in
touch with the Avengers on earth he'll
learn every friend he had left in the
universe is gone even surrounded by a
ship full of compatriots rocket is
impulsive depressed quick to anger and
bloodthirsty once he gets a gun in his
hands in guardians of the galaxy right
after Ronan ship crashes ons and our
rocket hopelessly charges the villain
because of how worked up he is over the
original fruits death now that he has
nothing to lose it's more likely than
ever that he'll do something stupid if
it gets Thanos in his crosshairs he's
not going to care about the consequences
even if it's fruitless from the start we
can probably count on the little guy to
run headlong into harm's way to get
revenge for Groot 2.0 rody war machine
stands a fair chance of kicking the
bucket and Avengers 4 as well for one
good reason of all the heroes to survive
infinity war he's the one that's already
deceased in the comics and at the hand
of Thanos no less he's also not exactly
a Marvel a Lister so there's a question
of what to do with rody if he were to
survive the story in the comics he
replaced Stark is Iron Man before taking
up the role of war machine but for now
Robert Downey jr. has left such a mark
on the role that the idea of a non
Downey Iron Man is all but impossible
remember the god of thunder not only is
Chris Hemsworth's contract coming to an
end with Avengers 4 but the events of
thor ragnarok and infinity war might
make you wonder whether the character
would even want to survive while thor
ragnarok ended on a hopeful note with a
few dozen Asgardian survivors bound for
earth to start a new infinity war opened
with the slaughter of most of the people
thor worked so hard to save most of
those refugees have perished Heimdall
and the warriors three are gone and
every bit of Thor's family blood-related
her otherwise his history as well and
since Asgard is destroyed Thor is now a
failed King even his fancy new weapon
proved to be unable to serve its purpose
of taking out that US with so much
wreckage behind him already
it's difficult to imagine anything
beyond a glorious demise would satisfy
his warrior spirit at this point the
princess considering how popular Shuri
has become since the release of black
panther it's likely comic book fans
worried for her throughout infinity war
Marvel readers know that T'Challa sister
held the mantle of Black Panther in the
comics for some time and eventually
sacrificed her life fighting fan OSes
cabal so that her brother could escape
popular though she is if Shuri were to
die in Avengers 4 it could lead to an
interesting opportunity for Black
Panther two went an AHA see Coates
helped relaunch the Black Panther comic
series in 2016 he ended the first issue
by revealing that T'Challa was
struggling with how to bring Shuri back
from the beyond
eventually Shuri did return and with
powers connected to the ancestral
origins of Wakanda if Shuri were to fall
when Avengers 4 and return in a fashion
similar to her comic book resurrection
it would give director Ryan Coogler a
chance to explore the more mystic side
of what conda's roots the monster how
else could Bruce Banner story possibly
end but to see that big Green Giant
disappear forever it's not just that
Mark Ruffalo's contract is up with
Avengers 4 or that the film is expected
to round out his supposed trilogy of
Hulk stories that started with Thor
Ragnarok they're also just aren't that
many imaginable futures left with the
character as we saw an infinity war Hulk
was hesitant to come out and do the
avengers bidding against Thanos
perhaps it's because Thanos gave him a
brutal beating like no other but perhaps
it also has something to do with the
fact that banner feels like he
disappears altogether whenever he's
transformed into the other guy in either
case the Hulk is not well liked on earth
thanks to his violently reckless
behavior in age of Ultron the only
chance that he might change anyone's
mind about him is if he goes out a hero
and saves more lives than he's cost the
world in the past thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]